ce que j'aime dans le modem c'est sa
liberté de penser sa liberté de parole
bonjour je m'appelle Marie Florence
bultour Rambaud j'ai 58 ans je j'habite
Marseille je suis adhérente œdème depuis
2014 depuis 2015 je suis conseillère
régionale élu donc sur une liste
d'ouverture et depuis 2021 je suis
vice-présidente de la Région
provence-alco d'Azur j'étais
précédemment à l'UMP et comme beaucoup
de gens je ne trouvais plus au sein de
l'UMP aucune référence à mes valeurs
vraiment fondamentalement centriste et
j'ai trouvé que le MoDem était la terre
d'accueil qui me convenait le mieux et
ne vend après je j'en suis toujours
persuadée ce que j'aime dans le modem
c'est sa liberté de penser sa liberté de
parole c'est sa fibre humaniste sa fibre
européenne qui correspondent
parfaitement à ce que je suis à ce que
je pense et aux prémices de mon
engagement politique j'ai 58 ans
aujourd'hui mais je me suis engagé
politiquement à 16 ans en 1981 au sein
du Mouvement des Jeunes du scariens au
sein de la région provençale-côte d'Azur
je suis vice-président dans de
l'éducation de l'orientation de
l'apprentissage et des lycées mes sujets
de prédilection sont ceux qui touchent à
la jeunesse et particulièrement à la
formation de la jeunesse qu'elle soit en
formation initiale par le biais des
lycées ou des lycées professionnels ou
alors par le biais de l'apprentissage le
vrai sujet stratégique depuis 2019 c'est
cette nouvelle compétence des régions
c'est-à-dire l'information sur les
métiers et le plus tôt possible puisque
dans cette nouvelle compétence les
régions ont le devoir d'aller parler
orientation auprès des collégiens et
c'est vraiment là où tout ce je suis
d'une génération où souvent on faisait
comme ses parents ou ce que voulait les
parents ça a été un peu mon cas j'ai un
père qui était scientifique et du coup
on m'a poussé à faire des études
scientifiques à mon époque
l'orientation c'était peu ou mal fait ou
pas fait du tout j'ai fait une licence
de biologie cellulaire à cette époque là
c'est créer un BTS de communication et
d'actions publicitaires donc j'ai quitté
une licence pour faire un BTS ce qui
bien évidemment n'a pas vraiment ravi
mes parents et en 2014 j'ai repris mes
études et j'ai fait Sciences Po ex